do you have to have a swastika tattoo as
a new Nazi today the the people rather
say
neo-nazis have to stay away from the
swastika yeah I think there's no other
symbol in the war in the world that you
can shock the people more with them with
the swastika and neo-nazis are trying to
to
um to pull in people from the middle of
society to their politics and you can't
do that with a swastika so new neo-nazis
try when they get a tattoo not to use
the swastikas anymore for me as a kid
from the 90s it was normal for me and
for my other comrades to tattoo a
swastika I used to have a swastik area
in the middle
um of my chest I put a new Nazis to
today try not to do to use these things